Japanese animation simultaneously one of
the most beautiful forms of animation
while also being one of the most
perverted the Secret World of Arrietty
comes out this weekend if you haven't
heard of it you can look it up on IMDB
or on tomatoes and see that it has a
whole bunch of great reviews which maybe
excited see this movie because I love
anime see I really like traditional
animation in America is really CGI
oriented nowadays and that's one of the
reasons why I really like anime because
it's a way to preserve traditional
animation but besides that I'm also a
nerd and that's why I like anime nothing
to do with anime chicks at all nothing
Oh Faye Valentine is so hot though this
film is a take on the classic tale the
borrower's no not the movie with John
Goodman the movies kind of funny though
you know it's a little people who live
in your house they come out at night to
take sugar cubes they take salt crystals
tissues little things like that they
borrow things from you and they have
these little houses and it's just it's
so cozy that if I were to pick one word
to define this movie it would be cozy
this is a beautifully animated movie and
a really great adventure I really like
this movie it was a lot of fun this one
was produced by Studio Ghibli now they
have made as far as I can tell three
films that are in the top 250 of IMDB
and there may be more how am i lucky
took part in this film very much so in
writing and I believe producing but he
did not direct this movie but that
company Studio Ghibli is responsible for
some of the best animation ever produced
films like spirited away my neighbor
totoro Princess Mononoke
you can watch films today like Toy Story
and really find a lot of enjoyment in
those movies and it's amazing some of
the things they can accomplish but there
is such a wonderful beautiful simplicity
in a hand-drawn picture that just
Springs with life and every image in
this movie is teeming with inventive
creation the things that we would look
at as you know seemingly insignificant
like the front yard for instance it's
like a wilderness filled with life
threatening things for these people and
it's so cool to look at things
differently that they're walking to the
inside of the walls you see rats the
rats are portrayed as these evil things
with red eyes the housecat that the
humans walk by and pet is looked at as
something very fear-inspiring and it's
all these kind of things that we take
for granted that caused so much of the
awesome drama and excitement in this
movie the version I saw was the English
dub version the voice work is very good
particularly for Arrietty and her
parents I didn't really like the voice
for the boy I didn't think he fit I just
didn't really buy into his performance
it seems strained and it didn't seem
like he was giving it his all the first
half the movie was very interesting and
filled with awe and Wonder once that
wore off the movie did lose a little
steam not too much though it just the
first half was better and that's always
a little disappointing I always like
when the last half really hits you but
the thing is when we did really well is
portray realistic characters even though
it's in this strange world I felt for
those little people I wanted them to be
safe I want them to be okay and so all
these the crazy action with the cats and
the crickets and roaches and everything
worked because of that this is a fun
movie it has beautiful animation if you
are fan traditional animation I suggest
checking this film out it comes out in
theaters this weekend I love CG
animation when it works it works but
there's something about traditional
animation that will always be closer to
my heart probably because I grew up with
it that's why I'm going to give the
secret World of Arrietty a B+ I really
like the movie I thought it was
beautifully animated and it's definitely
worth your time if you're interested in
this kind of thing and this isn't like
anime like nerd anime you know like
Dragon Ball Z which is awesome by the
way
this is a very well told animated tale
and I suggest you see it I like to note
do you have a favorite anime film mine
is probably Princess Mononoke that movie
just blew my mind in so many different
ways if you haven't seen Princess
Mononoke man that is a seriously good
movie and as you guys probably know the
introduction and part one to the your
viewers Awards aired yesterday and by
the time this video is up more than
likely part two will be up soon if it's
not I'll put the annotation for that
very soon look forward to that people
please show your support to the strong
film fan community that we're trying to
develop here I hope you guys enjoy the
show we'll be going through my videos
I'll check it out the links are in the
description below if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes